hey 42 here if you've ever found
yourself flipping Furniture as you
search frantically for your car keys
you'll know how easy it is to misplace
something maybe you lost your phone your
wallet or the will to live
but of all these the biggest mystery is
how we lost a billion years of History
this is far more serious than when you
found your keys in the bread bin because
there's a colossal Blank Spot in our
planet's past and nobody's quite sure
where we put it
to put things into perspective a billion
years is almost a quarter of Earth's
existence and yet there's a billion year
Gap in the fossil record that geologists
call the Great unconformity
let's dig a Little Deeper shall we
of which in he ran outside right now and
started to dig you'd uncover older
layers of rock the deeper you've got
first you'd find an Alanis Morissette
tape from the 90s maybe a disco ball
from the 70s but eventually you'd
excavate some Roman coins and other
assorted artifacts
so why is it that both human and natural
remains sink deeper into the Earth as
time passes
well the earth's surface is constantly
being littered with fine particles like
sand and dust this sediment accumulates
in an agonizingly slow process called
deposition then in another process
called cementation these mineral
particles gradually bind together until
a few million years later and
sedimentary rock is formed
then an overlay with rock forms on top
of that then another and another and so
on until the ground beneath your feet is
like a trifle a rock trifle with
millions of layers made over millions of
years and not a single one of them
contains custard
what a tragedy
but during all this sedimentation and
cementation animals are doing their
usual party trick of dying all the soft
squidgy bits get eaten or decomposed but
sometimes the harder bits like bones
shell and husk get covered in dust
slowly succumbing to the sedimentation
thus becoming encased in Rock over time
water penetrates this Rocky tomb which
dissolves the biological remains within
eventually minerals fill that void and
form a fossil which of course is just a
rock replica of the creature that once
resided there
importantly though that fossil is Frozen
in time enshrined in the sedimentary
rock from the era in which the animal
lift
much of our understanding of the history
of the planet and life itself has come
through studying the sequence of
sedimentary rock layers and the
treasures they've trapped Through Time
often the different layers called strata
are clear and distinct with each
revealing something unique about the age
it was formed in the stupendously fun
pastime of studying strata is called
stratigraphy
and one of its guiding principles is the
law of superposition which states that
if undisturbed the lower down the rock
layer the older The Rock not exactly
Rock it's science but it does mean that
generally when you're looking at a
cross-section of geologic formations you
get a fairly neat picture of the passage
of time but unfortunately history isn't
so predictable whilst new layers of
sedimentary rock are being formed in one
location in another conditions can
change and sedimentation just stops wind
and water erosion can move particles
elsewhere effectively deleting part of a
geologic record
after a while sedimentation might resume
in that location but these temporary
interruptions will forever leave a gap
in that Rock's record and sometimes that
Gap called a Hiatus can be millions of
years long it's like hitting pause
rewind and then record again whilst in a
very long conversation in the final
recording there will be missing parts
that are irrecoverable and if these
parts are integral to the meaning of
said conversation then the whole thing
will no longer make any sense
when these hiatuses happen it creates a
noticeable difference in the angle color
and texture of the new rock that sits on
top as can be seen here and here
geologists call this feature an
unconformity
it was Danish Man Neil steensen
considered the father of stratigraphy
who first sketched in unconformity back
in 1669 but it was a Scottish farmer
called James Hutton who discovered the
first significant unconformity
whilst walking near sicker point in
Scotland in 1787 he noticed a striking
difference between the lower and upper
rock formations and so he coined a name
for it Hutton's unconformity if that
name sounds a little rude to you but
you're not really sure why
join the club
anyway the grayish lower layer of rock
is made up of deep sea deposits from
around 425 million years ago but the
reddish upper layer was deposited by
rivers and streams about 345 million
years ago that's a Hiatus of about 80
million years
it was on the back of this discovery
that Hutton helped develop some major
theories about the movement of tectonic
plates and the forces that shape the
face of the Earth some geologists call
sick a point a geologic Shrine which
tells you how incredibly strange both
this formation and geologists actually
are
however the most unusual unconformity
was found in 1869 when John Wesley
Powell was observing a strange Mound
whilst traversing the Grand Canyon
noticed a vertical rock formation
botting up against horizontal formations
channeling the Supreme creativity of his
geologist predecessors he named it
Powell's on conformity
but since then it's been more commonly
referred to as Powell's great on
Conformity and there are two striking
reasons why it's deserving of a great
firstly the unconformity actually spans
an entire continent stretching across
laurentia which is the name for the
ancient heart of North America
secondly many other unconformities had
been Unearthed around the world at this
point but they mostly represented small
gaps on a planetary scale at least maybe
tens of millions of years
but the smallest time gap between the
two Rock players in the great
unconformity is a modest 250 million
years and the biggest is over 1.2
billion years that's right that missing
piece of prehistoric pie sandwiched
between these two unassuming rock
formations represents up to 1.2 billion
years of missing history and we have no
idea where it went
but there's so much more to this Rocky
weirdness since Powell's Grand Discovery
a few more formations have been found
all over the world that have the same
time period plucked from their record
together we collectively refer to these
as the great unconformity it's a mystery
that spans the entire planet and over a
billion years of missing knowledge
take the Grand Canyon example here the
525 million year old Cambrian era Tapia
Sandstone sits snugly on top of the 1.7
billion year old this new basement rocks
dating back to the pre-cambrian era
like I said a Time gap of 1.2 billion
years
weird right
Scuttle over to the Ozark plateau in
Missouri where we see a similar sight
500 million year old Sandstone sits
suspiciously atop 1.4 billion year old
Granite representing a 900 million year
Hiatus for the sake of all that is
igneous what's the metamorphic heck is
going on here well some have suggested a
theory to explain the great unconformity
and it's called the snowball Earth
theory it refers to a time during the
cryogenium period around 650 million
years ago when the Earth's surface was
thought to be covered by glaciers and
ice sheets like a giant snowball
Glaciers are capable of causing erosion
on a massive scale as they grind across
Landscapes and it's been estimated that
they collectively removed two to three
miles from the Earth's surface
basically the Earth had its face
exfoliated now do you remember me saying
that the younger rocks that sit Atop The
Great unconformity all around the world
date back to a period called the
Cambrian Period
well what's really interesting here is
that the Cambrian Period was when the
biggest explosion of life in our
planet's history took place during a
tiny timeline of only 11 million years
between approximately
541 and 530 million years ago the
original ancestors of almost all the
life forms we currently know today
sprang into existence
for example this is when fish first
appeared
there was life before this event sure
but this short window was when mother
nature downed a Red Bull snorted some
cocaine and hit the big evolutionary
boost button
so how does all this relate to the
snowball Earth theory
when all these eyes flow started to hit
the ocean they deposited gargantuan
quantities of nutrient-rich minerals
into the water where the theory goes it
was responsible for the aforementioned
explosion of life
over 1 billion years of sedimentary rock
was just carved from the face of the
planet by glaciers then plunged into
Evolution's breeding ground the ocean
where the many minerals contained within
acted as a catalyst for Life as we know
it today so in the end it looks like we
did lose a billion years of History down
the back of the sofa only the sofa in
question turns out to be the bottom of
the ocean but snowball Earth remains a
theory one that was only posed as
recently as 1998 by Dr Paul Hoffman and
if you ask me two decades doesn't seem
like enough time to definitively explain
a billion years of missing history maybe
someday new techniques or technologies
will rock the geology world and enable
us to fill in more of the missing gaps
in our planets very long very empty
history book but until then the great
unconformity will remain a great mystery
thanks for watching